[Music]
well thank you all so much for joining
welcome to the rstudio enterprise
community meetup i'm rachel dempsey i'm
calling in from boston
and i'll be your host for today's meetup
and i'm so excited to be joined by yab
and shore today
but if you've just joined now feel free
to introduce yourselves through the chat
window and say hello maybe put in where
you're calling in from
but just to go through a brief agenda
while we wait for a few others from the
waiting room we'll go through some
introductions of the meetup
have a great presentation on the
clusterbuster app and the organizational
aspects of of putting that into
production was shored
and then how to build a production shiny
app some of the more technical aspects
from yum
and then a fun ask us everything open
discussion time
for you to ask anything that that's on
your mind about presentations and shiny
and production in general
just a quick note that the recording
will be shared up to the rstudio youtube
so you can always ask questions
anonymously through slido if you don't
want to be part of
that recording as well
but i will share that slido link with
you in just a moment
you can upload other people's questions
too and that will help us organize the
questions
one other zoom note if you want to turn
on live transcription you can do so
during the talk as well so in the zoom
bar below you could just press more and
turn that on
and i see that a few people did so
awesome
for anyone who's joining for the first
time welcome to the art studio
enterprise community meetup
just to kind of let you know what this
group is
this is a friendly and open meetup
environment for teams to share the work
they're doing within their organizations
teach lessons learned network with
others
and really just allow us all to learn
from each other so thank you all so much
for making this a welcoming community
we really want to create a space where
everybody can participate and we can
hear from everyone so just like to
reiterate that we love to hear from
everyone no matter your level of
experience in the field or the industry
that you're working in
i'll share a few links towards the end
of the meetup if you ever want to give
suggestions or general feedback
on the meetup
or if you may be interested in speaking
at some point in the future too we'd
love to hear from you
but with that that's enough from me and
i'd love to turn it over to you short
for the first presentation
thank you
all right so this is my first
presentation on the cluster buster in
english so if you see me struggling for
words at some point please forgive me
give me a couple of seconds
um i will figure out a way to put my
thoughts into words eventually so
i'm here to talk about the
the cluster buster which is an
application for the surveillance of
covet 19.
we made this for the rfm in the
netherlands and i'm going to talk
well i'm going to talk a little bit more
about the rivm and what that is exactly
but mainly i'm going to talk about the
process to to creating valuable insights
with our shiny
so let's see i can move this yeah these
windows around
so
um
first of all a little introduction uh
about myself my name is shud virenha
which is a dutch name hard to pronounce
so you can call me stewart if you want
to that's no problem i studied public
administration
a decade back
worked in healthcare for a couple of
years and finally decided that i wanted
to learn how to program
so as you can see i am not an
epidemiologist i'm not a doctor so i'm
not going to talk about the virus about
covet or omicron i'm going to talk about
about the application and how to get
things done within the context of the
organization that i that i worked in i
started working at the
rivm a little over a year ago
it was tuesday december
1st 2020 so
it's not too long ago but to be honest
um it was a
weird time so it feels like um like a
century ago a little summary introduced
myself while i just did in the river
i'll talk a little bit about that
i'll talk about an intriguing yet
slightly abstract question that i was
being asked in december of 2020 the
context within which we operate
and the approach that we took to produce
value
fast well that's a relative term let's
say uh
well let's say it was fast
and then
the final bit i need to move this screen
around
i will talk a little bit about the
results of our efforts and maybe give
you a sneak preview into some of our
following work
so i i practiced this talk a little bit
with my colleague yap who will be
talking later on
and i noticed that i had too many slides
so i think i have 37 38 so i'm going to
skip over them pretty quickly
they will be downloadable at some point
rachel will probably share a link to
that
so if you have any questions just just
ask
um yeah so maybe i'm going a bit too
fast so if you have any questions just
ask
yes then we can share this link to the
slides with the recording which will go
up to youtube as well and on the meetup
perfect all right so what is the rivm it
is the national institute for public
health and environment it's part of the
dutch government and it houses the
center for infectious disease control
which is the
the dutch cdc i guess you could say
there we have the department of data
innovation and signaling where i work
and then uh finally i was allowed to
form my own team which is team cluster
buster
which i'll be talking a little bit more
about later on
as i said before i want to start off
with the slightly abstract question that
i was being asked in december of 2020
which was can we help municipal health
services gain insight into data
concerning the clustering of cases this
is one of those questions that you need
to really ponder on a little bit to
fully understand what's going on here so
i had a lot of questions when somebody
asked me this what do you mean exactly
by municipal health services who do you
mean
there are a lot of doctors working there
epidemiologists but also researchers
policy makers decision makers who are we
referring to when we say we want to
to share insights with these
organizations
gain insight into data like what kind of
insights do you mean what kind of data
do you mean what kind of data do we have
and what do you mean by the clustering
of cases
um by cases do you mean some
mathematical approximation of the amount
of covered 19 that was circulating or do
you mean reported cases so as you can
imagine there were a lot of questions
for me to to ask during the month of
december 2020 so
that's what i i started off with
so i said well i am very intrigued but i
need to ask a lot more questions to
fully understand
the problem
here a little bit about the context
i was talking about this municipal
health services i don't know if you have
something equivalent to this in your
country but we have 25 of them in the
netherlands they cover certain areas
certain municipalities and they are at
the front line of fighting covet 19
and there are a lot of doctors
in infectious disease control working
there epidemiologists and they are
responsible for testing and vaccination
in the netherlands they also have a
local advisory function so
it does happen that sometimes an
organization is closed because they
refuse to adhere to the the national
guidelines
and these mhs's these municipal health
services have an advisory function on
that as well
these 25 regions are subdivided into
seven regions
and let's be honest they've been in in
crisis mode for close to two years and i
think that that is a very important
observation also concerning uh this talk
so this is the netherlands
uh you all know this this is uh the 25
municipal health regions
and this is where the netherlands is
situated i believe you are in boston
right uh rachel
i am yes but i see people are joining
from all over the world everywhere
i was expecting a lot more
american but it's it's really all over
the world so well you'll probably know
where the netherlands is
if not i refer you to google earth
um so let's start off with the approach
now which is i guess the most important
part of this presentation but a little
disclaimer to begin with you have this
saying under pressure everything becomes
fluid uh we use it a lot in dutch as
well
on the drug what are fluid we say and i
i i put this at the start of my
uh of the main part of this presentation
because
um this is not a normal organization in
in in coffee 19 times and this is also
it's it's not a normal era sort of so to
speak
so i was thinking what is it that i want
to share
in my presentation i want to share
something that you can actually take
with you to your organization also in
normal times because
a lot of things were different now there
was more money to get things done there
was less bureaucracy etc but
um keep this in mind as i as i continue
my talk
and i tried to to really focus in on the
things that you could take with you to
your organization during normal times
hopefully very soon
so as i said before i was faced with a
problem and i really wanted to
understand this problem properly
before continuing so i wanted to have a
clear view of who our customers were
which is not a term you hear often in a
public domain organization but
it's it's really relevant who are we
working for exactly is it the decision
makers is it the researchers
we decided that it is actually the
doctors and epidemiologists that work at
these mhs's that we want to inform
so we had a clear definition of our
customer
what kind of data do we have
well we have the source investigation
and contact tracing data so anytime you
test positive for covert you will be
called by one of the employees of the
mhs when you live in the netherlands and
they will ask you where have you been
who have you been in contact with where
do you think that you may have
contracted the virus
in all likelihood and this data is being
sent to the rivm and we use this to
create well let's say actionable
insights this was at least
our wish from the very beginning we want
to not just create insights on things
that people want to know but there need
to be some action tied to the to the
inside
um
the doctors and epidemiologists in the
mhs's they advised the executive branch
so we wanted to give them the insights
to have as good as an advice as possible
to eventually this was one of the goals
bust clusters this is what the woman
that hired me actually told me
that uh they wanted to go
busting clusters so i was like what does
that mean this is actually an
epidemiological term and i thought to
myself that is a great name for an shiny
application so i i kept using that
and eventually when we went to
production and started opening our
application to um
to doctors and epidemiologists i was
like maybe we should find a a more
formal name for this application
but this this doctor i spoke to said no
no you definitely need to keep it called
the cluster buster because that is a
great name so it's been called the
cluster buster ever since and i'm very
happy
that we stuck with it
so this is an example of what happened
in the netherlands i believe this
happened in the us as well
this is a meat processing plant that was
shut down because there were too many
positive uh covet tests reported back to
this facility
um
they were not adhering to the guidelines
so this one got closed this happened
over 200 times i believe in the
netherlands in 2020 so um yeah giving
advice on
on where covet clusters
is actually a really relevant thing to
do
another part of the problem is
not all 25 regions had proper access to
actionable insights this was obviously a
main part of the problem they did not
have the insights they did have the data
because they collected but they did not
have sometimes the analytical talent or
the tools
to um to come up with
insights that were
valuable so
some did some had great
tools they had great dashboards there
was already in our shiny dashboard
produced in one of these mhs some had
great reports so one of the main
questions that we asked ourselves is
what are the best practices that we see
um
in these mhs's and can we replicate them
and can we redistribute them to all 25
so that was one of the main the main
goals we had in mind
to do this i first had to have a clear
understanding
of
whether or not it was possible to share
insights and obviously you have some
prerequisites when you want to do this
you have some legal boundaries we cannot
share all the data you have
gdpr privacy regulations in every
country i believe
everyone in this meeting has their own
version of gdpr we had as well so there
were some boundaries limitations to what
we were allowed to share obviously the
data had some limitations
and the technology had some limitations
so i needed to have a clear
understanding of what our limitations
and possibilities were
but once i i had this understanding
my advice was actually to move forward
with with our shiny
so i use this metaphor a lot but it was
a little bit of a 100 meter hurdle run
like what are the hurdles that we need
to pass
one by one in order to to get to our
final goal so do we have legal hurdles
do we have technological hurdles do we
lack some data but can we get it these
are the kind of kinds of questions that
we asked ourselves in the very early
beginning
so finally i said yeah well i think our
shiny is actually the right tool for the
job
and it was actually a logical choice in
my view why because a lot of the data
preparation covered 19 data in the
netherlands was already done in r
a lot of people working at the rivm
are familiar with r and there was
already some experience with our shiny
applications
so
based on my prior experience and my
first weeks of investigation at the rivm
i knew for a fact that we could produce
value with are shiny
but this was just me our shiny is still
quite a new tool although some of you
might disagree but for organizations
it's still at some point quite new
so i had to do some convincing so
what i did was i created a prototype of
which you see a screenshot here
and i use this to to show that uh our
shiny can actually produce
great looking and valuable
dashboards valuable insights this one is
uh still online
and i guess i can probably share a link
to this
at some point maybe later on rachel
yes
people can uh
look at it themselves
yeah
so yeah it's probably most fun if you
can just click through it yourselves but
i created this prototype because i still
needed to convince some people that our
shiny was actually the right tool for
the job
and this is highly recommended
um yeah they they got really
enthusiastic so eventually i got the
green light and they said well uh should
we trust you
um
uh
yeah let let's go for it and and uh
create a team do whatever you think is
necessary to to create this application
and share insights with these mhs's
so i got the green lights to
uh to build my own team i wanted it to
be as vertically integrated as possible
i wanted a team to be able to produce 80
to 90 percent of the application all by
itself obviously some of the work is too
specialized to to do within your team
so uh we had to rely on on the it
department a bit as well you will talk a
little bit more about that later on
we were meeting very often well let's
say three times a week we had a um a
daily stand-up meeting
and we would be meeting uh in between
those obviously uh pretty often
so we had a sort of an agile
working style let's say it was rapid
iteration it was not agile to the to the
t
but it was agile uh in spirit
and there was a lot of enthusiasm i
think this is really a result of
vertical integration and working in an
agile way
um because we were capable of doing so
much ourselves
um at some times we we got a request for
an insight and we could deliver the same
day and that is a great way of working
this is also thanks to uh to our shiny
impart
and and to the well the special skills
that we had in our team so this
vertically integrated way of working
really got
really helped us um
and and made us very enthusiastic in the
process
so this is our team i stole this picture
from from yop
i believe he drew it himself which is
amazing i didn't know that uh he had
that talent as well
but this is our team we're seven of us
right now
but we started off with a very small
team
with myself and you'll see she is my
colleague that uh is responsible for the
coordination of doctors and
epidemiologists that work at the rivm
um so we started off with you'll see
with yop and with myself but we
gradually build towards a larger team
and each and every one of them have
their own part to play so this is
the team uh seven people but i think all
in all it's probably two full-time
employees it counts up to two fte that
we use to to create this product which
in my view is still really quite amazing
that we were able to do so much with uh
with so little this is
probably quite a convincing argument for
um decision makers in your organization
as well
so january 2021 there was some
understanding of the problem
the prerequisites were met we had our
weapon of choice which was our shiny and
there was a team so now what
we were all ready to to go
but um yeah what what what was the
approach
and i think that this is the single most
important question in this entire
process is how do you allocate as much
of your energy as possible towards
creating value and obviously to be able
to do this you need to have a clear
definition of value and as i said before
i'm not a doctor nor am i an
epidemiologist
so nor am i an end user of the
application
so we said to ourselves we need some
some sort of a feedback loop from the
users themselves from the
um the experts themselves so we put
together an advisory board yossi and me
containing of doctors and
epidemiologists that work at the mhs so
they were the representatives so to
speak
of our user group
together with them
we had a strong focus on actionable
insights as much as possible obviously
sometimes you create an insight just
because it provides some background
information that that that's useful in
getting a
situational awareness
but we were
definitely
focused towards creating insights that
uh
that
could lead to some action um in practice
not just
a nice to know thing
for me personally
my most important role in this advisory
board was balancing between requests and
possibilities so oftentimes
the the advisory board would put down a
request shoot is this something that you
can make and i would balance this out
with uh with legal possibilities as well
as technological possibilities
and we will have
weekly meetings with this uh this
advisory board so here you can see this
rapid iteration weekly meetings we would
provide feedback on fridays on what we
did and we would continue to look
forward
at trying to find new insights that we
could produce that would would help out
even more
so this is this is
one of the sentences that i showed
through this advisory board every week
um
this is the task of the advisory board
it is in dutch but it doesn't really
matter for now what it was is it was a
constant reminder that we had to work
towards creating valuable insight so
very strong focus on that let's not
waste energy doing things for fun let's
work towards
insights that actually add some value
so this is the structure that we
end up with
all the way at the top you see our user
group
they are represented by the advisory
board and through the advisory board we
collect requests the development team
collect requests and they start working
on realizing those and obviously
in the background there's a lot of
specialists that that helped us out with
for example legal questions or i.t
related questions
um so yeah i think all in all
just around 30 people maybe helped us
out with uh with what i said legal and
it matters
so what did we end up with we ended up
with an application and our shiny
application that provided insights into
vaccinations so what you see here is a
map
with uh the vaccination rate i believe
it's called for every neighborhood and
every age group and we also combined
this with
the amount of positive reports so this
is a bivariate choroplethic choropleth
map
so you have the bifariate part is the
vaccination rate versus the amount of
infections in the last week
everything you see here obviously is
fake data
we had some tables i'm not going into
depth in all to all of those
this is
a visualization of clusters so on the
left here you see some of these clusters
this could be a workplace maybe or a
school or a nursing home and if you
clicked on one of those on the right you
would see where the
the linked casters were situated
so this is one of the requests that was
put forward by the advisory board
and uh thanks to our shiny actually we
could
uh
realize this i'm not sure if we could
have done this in any in any other tool
for us it was really
relatively easy to create these kinds of
insights with uh with our shiny so i i
seldom they had to sell a no to to a
request from the advisory board which
was
a nice way of working
uh yeah we used sparklines you'll talk a
little bit more about the packages we
used to create all these insights
so finally we had a pretty cool
application we thought it was very
valuable but obviously this didn't sell
itself so i had to give a lot of
presentations i think i i
um
i spoke to almost every region in the
netherlands we
have had some newsletters
with regular updates and obviously we we
are doing a little bit of work on
outreach
because um
we don't think that the product sells
itself so to speak so there was a little
bit of technology
push if you can call it that but
eventually we started noticing that a
lot of people started asking for
authorization
so
all in all now we have
almost 400 doctors and epidemiologists
that use our tool
so that's what we did in the meantime
for the last couple of uh months let's
say last uh
10 months already we have been producing
insights we are approaching 400 users
and they are
from all 25 mhs regions so this is
something that we're actually pretty
proud of
we know that the application is being
used we know this because we track it
quantitatively obviously also we ask it
to to the mhss how do you use it why do
you use it and what can we what can we
improve i literally call them or send
them an email to to get some qualitative
feedback as well
they use these insights to stay up to
date on covered 19 clusters and they
have also used our application for the
allocation of mobile vaccination units
so they have a limited number of mobile
vaccination units and one of the
questions they ask themselves obviously
is what is the best place to to locate
this mobile vaccination unit which could
be a bus or something like that and
they use the cluster buster to to to
find the optimal spot for that
and one of the night nice
how you say this
side effects was that the data quality
actually improved because
the mhs started using the cluster buster
so they they finally saw the reason for
the reason for keeping track of all
different types of data we gave them
back insights and this motivated them to
to really pay attention to the quality
of their data
yeah well
i put this in this is just to say that
we are already working on our next
application
this is this is one that um i hope to
that we will release let's say in the
next month or so
and this is uh we will take everything
we learned from the cluster buster and
put it in in our next application this i
hope and we are working towards this
is going to be open source so i'm hoping
to share this share the code behind this
application so all of you can see how we
did this exactly and
can create your own tiny new cluster
busters for
whatever use you prefer
so main takeaways
for me i guess the most important ones
are
have a very clear understanding of the
problem
which i talked about a lot before
creating convincing prototype if your
organization is not already used to
using our shiny especially for a public
use create a convincing prototype
or just show what we have made
it's
ready for your use i guess
vertical integration helped us out a lot
because we
could create insights
very quickly so rapid iteration was
possible
very important to have a clear
definition of value so for us we had our
advisory board
i i say here clear ish definition of
value because
what is valuable may change over time so
at first
we said that it would be very valuable
to have insight into clusters of covert
90 and this is still valuable
information but at some point we started
focusing a little bit more on
insights into vaccination data so the
definition of value may change obviously
over time
incorporate your user feedback keep a
strong focus on what your definition of
value is
i noticed that it's important to promote
your products don't don't think that it
will sell itself well it might
eventually but really do some promoting
and ask why a lot this may be
particularly necessary if you work in
the
in the public domain where it's not it's
not always just about efficiency so you
need to ask why a lot why do we do this
and finally for us at least i think that
our shiny was an excellent
excellent choice especially because
we got to develop our insights as close
as possible to the wish of our end user
and i think that is
very valuable
and this is this is what got us so
enthusiastic in using our shiny so
i guess that's it yeah that was my last
slide already
was i
thank you so much
yes that was perfect
i see
i see a lot of great questions coming in
already as well so i'd love to cover
a few of those too sure
right now and i see a lot of clapping by
everybody although you can't hear us we
are glad
that's nice one of the um most upvoted
questions so far
was when you first introduced shiny
what other tools were you comparing it
to standard bi tools and how did you
explain the difference to your leaders
that's a really good question
i was comparing it to
tableau power bi all the tools that i i
knew
and for me i also already from the very
beginning had a clear focus on our shiny
because we were working so much with r
so it was very
logical choice for me to investigate so
in that sense it was um
it was already
our shiny was in the lead already
because we were doing so much with uh
with our
yeah
thank you i see a lot of other great
questions coming in too and one that i
see jacqueline you just asked one would
you want to ask that live
or i can read it too
but the question was what were the most
important aspects of your prototype app
to create buy-in
i'm sorry come again
what were the most important aspects of
your prototype app to create buy-in
right so i i think that the overall
um
looks of it and the
the
the swiftness how would you say this
like
the the
um the visualizations that were in there
all worked really
smoothly i should say so the overall
user experience was i think good and
this is something that not everyone was
expecting from from our shiny that is
because it's still quite new and
sometimes you see tools that are
not that flashy or shiny looking so i
thought it was really important to to to
make something that people
instantly got a feel for that that they
wanted to work with it so our looks were
actually really really important it's
not so much about the technological
aspects of it like oh we can use these
packages and it will all um
be fantastic in in coding and whatever
no
i wanted to convince them by just making
something that looks really cool it's
maybe a bit
simple but yeah that was important
yeah i loved the marketing
of the app that
that the team did and just like thinking
about naming or applications too
yeah having fun names for them
yeah yeah exactly so imagine that you're
a doctor an epidemiologist during these
this this crisis and you
um
there's you work 60 hours a week 80
hours a week i don't know and then you
are asked to use an application that
just doesn't look good it doesn't work
it's slow whatever this is the last
thing that you want you really want to
create an application that people would
want to use even if they are working 50
60 70 hour work weeks
during this crisis so yeah that was not
just important for prototyping this was
important for the use of the application
definitely
i see a lot of other great questions
that also touch on some of the technical
aspects so i may wait until we get to
young's uh presentation and then we can
ask some of those at the end too
if that sounds good yeah perfect yeah
perfect well thank you all for for
putting those questions in there too
just a reminder to anyone who joined
i'll i'll show you a slido link again
but you can ask questions there with
your name or anonymously and you can
upload other people's questions too
but with that i'd love to turn it over
to the next presentation
with jab who will go through some of the
more technical aspects of actually
putting this shiny app into production
give a short introduction i'm job
striker i'm a geochemist at the national
institute of public health and
environment i work at the environmental
department
and
i already work with r for i think at
least 20 years or something i do a lot
of data analysis with r
and the last years uh in our division we
all really had to put out some shiny
applications uh on the internet we used
docker technology for that uh that was
the reason that she would ask me for
this project because he needed some back
attention here to do this this work so
although i'm a data scientist i wasn't
called for my geochemical knowledge
because that wasn't needed but
mostly for my engineering skills
so that was my role in this
in this in his team
well you should already told something
about administrative municipal health
services they collect a lot of data from
you let's let's consider that that's you
somewhere there having a covet test and
they collect your your name your address
your phone number your social security
number uh if you are affected or not or
not and if you are infected they do a
source investigation a contact tracing
they ask about you whereabouts the
people you are we are in contact with
etc and they also collect data about
your vaccination so that's it's quite a
lot of sensitive data about you
now
this is us we're a data science team and
our assignment was a little bit
rephrased and what you told us but the
oscars just fill with that very private
data
create some information out of it put it
on the internet and make sure only
people who are allowed to see it can
actually see it
and this is actually the moment you have
to get out of your chair because
you start yelling at us because
as data scientists how can you be sure
that that very sensitive data is in our
good hands and that we have
enough knowledge about security to make
this application actually secure
um
so actually we have
from an engineering point of view we
have three challenges first you have to
create this information you have to
create the dashboard that was
the least of our concerns
you have to work with the all the
privacy issues in europe you have this
gdpr the general data protection
regulations which is very strict about
privacy and we're talking about medical
personal
personal medical data which is the most
sensitive data that we have
and we have to do a privately privacy
impact assessment we have to
talk to our privacy officers
and that's a lot of paperwork and part
of the paperwork is to describe how we
physically
in it terminology secure
our
data
and we are data scientists we're not
security experts
so this was the biggest biggest
challenge
um before i go into how we solved it um
i'll show you a little bit about the
data flow that we have here we have the
landscape with all these municipal
health services they collect all the
data and part of the data they send to
the rf here using a myriad of systems
there are about eight different
systems within these
images
this data is collected in a database or
two and then we have our own data
science team
said students department which actually
extract data from this these databases
and create all kind of data products
reports graphs visualization whatsoever
which is which are used
for combating this discovery crisis
and all these data products are stored
on a network file storage
and we take it from there um
so
this is from the
back end side now if you're going to
look to the other side
this is how you want to
make this data available again to the
mhs
we decided to create this application
using a docker environment we use an
openshift kubernetes environment for
that
and
what we did is that we said or we put
this web application in in a dmz
which is an open uh
a piece of a network which is open to
the uh
to the world
and
we use our f5 proxy server for the
authorization
and the biggest advancement is that
this
processor was a
building block a service which was
provided by rt department so they were
taking care of the authorization and it
means that the people at the mhs can
log in using their own credentials it's
like logging in using a google account
to some other website so log in with
their own
credentials
passing through the proxy and then
having access to the
to the application
and also the
thing what we did was that if somebody
logs in then we know which user it is so
again
uh we based on the username we provide
the user with only the data which is he
or
he or she is allowed to see
it means that somebody makes an error
here at the mhs and authorize somebody
who is allowed to log in but
we haven't received any message or we
don't know him then it will the person
will get access to the application but
don't have access to the data
so in case of a data breach
now let's
first it means that this application
isn't accessible if you don't have an
authorization so if you are some some
bad guy
somebody who wants to
do something with that application it
means that you don't even come near it
uh however if you can get near the
application and uh start hanging around
it means that you only can have access
to the
to the container environment and to the
data contained in that container
environment
the
internal
data the file storage it was completely
blocked off because there was a one-way
firewall between it so the only thing we
could do is push our data through the
container and it's not the other way
around but this was one way to secure
also security data
and these were all services or
building blocks or tools provided by the
it department and also stuff which the
it department could maintain so
we can deliver an application and we
still can and trust on the
on the experts of the it department
securing everything
now if you look at the total pick okay
let's first have a look at how we
had our own process
what we did is that we had this
information created by the data
scientist scientist team on this service
network
and we had a small linux virtual machine
running all kinds of crown jobs and
doing the data preparation in the
beginning the machine was doing quite a
lot of heavy lifting on the data and
nowadays a lot of this heavy lifting is
done by the data science team
and we only have to do some small
adjustments to the data
but on this machine a sqlite database is
created and this database is pushed
through this one way only firewall onto
the container platform which is running
docker containers and these are contains
quickly
contain the application
and of course we'll use a
a good repository with with the code and
this combined is this this completes the
application so this total picture of how
we
created this this architecture is that
we have
our data science teams who are doing the
the first step in the data preparation
then it's our team who's actually
creating the databases and the
application
but
by
launching the application and making the
application available to the other world
that's done on this container platform
which was managed by the i.t department
that means that we can focus on creating
an application while all the security
issues
are
the responsibility of the t department
and
these
guys they have the right experts to make
sure that only the
right people can access this application
so this is how we solved our biggest
issue around
security and these are all kind of
building blocks which were available
within our institute
it took a while to to stick everything
together but now we have
a
environment which we think is pretty
pretty secure at least secure enough for
this kind of sensitive data
so this is a bit about the architecture
um
now let's focus a little bit more on the
application but before that i want to
talk about uh
our team um should already introduce us
um at the beginning
we were just a bunch of data scientists
but an application like this requires
teamwork so uh we decided pretty early
already on certain team roles uh who's
going to do what
in my case i do the back-end engineering
uh julian did visualization shoot it a
lot of talking etc etc um
and the uh
also at these regular standard meetings
so we had very short communications with
each other
and we also decided very quickly to put
everything on github in a private
repository
that means the code not the data of
course
i haven't decided to work with branches
and with issue branches etc just on the
uh
like net launcher teams uh i used to do
um
and we created we created several
containers for several stages of our
application so we have a
development version which is just for us
developers we have a testing version
just to make sure everything works we
have an acceptance version this is a
version actually which is also
accessible from the outside the auto can
only be accessed from the inside
so we can show some new things and we
have a production version and using this
kind of
well
uh
tiered uh
versions it means that when we are at
the moment that we want to put something
in production we are pretty sure it's
solid it works and
users are
wants to work with it
well we chose for shiny obviously
but one of the things we also decided is
that we
are going to split up this whole shiny
application in shiny modules if you
create a any serious shiny applications
i think you should use shiny modules
with modules you make it much more
easier to
to maintain and to reuse code i'll come
to back
to come to that later
but as i said we use sqlite as a
database
powering the app escolite is very
portable it's just one single file which
is very easy to move around
and we use the pool package to access
the
the escrow light
for the visualizations we use high
charts and height charts is a
visualization library which is almost
the default in for dutch for the dutch
government
it's a
a
you need a paid license
for it so it's not free
but we have the license and you know
these the visualizations that aj just
look cool
we use shine locks to track usage
and for the visualizations of the maps
we use leaflet and simple features
and we also use spark lines so our
tables look pretty cool
these are the the main packages
i will go into some some details first
these these modules if you look at the
application that we created
the total application contains about 75
different visualizations however there's
a lot of reuse it means that we can
create a 75 visualizations with about 25
modules this also includes modules for
titles and stuff like that
and reuse makes it makes it very easy
that you can reuse all your
or your code for example there's a
setting page in this
in this application where you can see
what the affections are
depending on different settings like
nursery homes of like schools
and
these
these pages they contain all the same
visuals but if you use modules you just
create create one module and you can use
and a module is one single visual you
can use that visual on different pages
and different locations inside your
inside your applications
and also for maintaining your code
it's also very easy because if there's
something wrong with the visualization
you immediately immediately know where
to look at which part of the code is
causing the troubles
what we also did is that we
organized our code uh
and what we use what we call subscripts
if you look at the server.file for such
a huge application it's about hundreds
maybe thousands of lines and we just
chopped it up in different
sections and
source it using a source local
command and this makes also the code
more maintainable it also means that if
you work as a team it's much easier to
work with one person on a single file
because if you work works with
multiple persons on the same file you
have the risk of conflict so it makes
things well a little bit more difficult
so that was what
was one of the things that we also did
to split up the uh
the code and make it easier to maintain
the application or to add new new
features
one of the things with what's very
important for us is the tracking of the
usage of the
few applications we really wanted to
know how are users interacting with our
applications of course you can ask what
they're doing but it's also nice to have
some
quantitative data about it so we use
shiny locks as in as a package
and i think
shiny locks is well it's it's a great
package for that however there were some
privacy issues which finally works one
of the things what shiny looks like was
it was recording
the ip number and the ip number is a
well
an identifiable number which can
identify a person so and according to
our privacy statement we cannot record
it so what we did is that we wrote some
functions so now we rewrote some
functions of shiny logs and then
overloaded them
in the library using the assign in
namespace
so we make some little adjustments to
this to this package without actually
altering the package
um
[Music]
and
what channel does is store all the data
that that has a
also an sqlite database and we created
even a separate
dashboard out of it so we could just
follow the
user interaction
all right
these were just some details of course
when you're working with an application
you're always always thinking what are
the next steps that we're going to do
one of the things i really like to look
into is using regression tests
we are creating a
shiny application but
testing takes quite a lot of time if you
can automate this this uh somehow it
will
really contribute to your speed of of
coding and speed of adding new features
it's not implemented right now in
cluster buster but
we're thinking of it to do it for uh for
next version
um also
one of the things that we want to look
into the communication between all these
reactive elements in such an
application
we think it can be more efficient but
it's also
if you're working with it
it it always gives me headaches
so we really have to think about it
once
and also for other applications i'm not
sure if you're gonna apply it to a next
version of cluster bus or at least for
other applications we're working with
we're thinking about using frameworks
like golem or something else
just to make the development
cycle a little bit
faster
and we really like to make this open
source however it's
not on top of our list we're very busy
the the the govic numbers are soaring
high here so
um
but we really like to make it open
source so maybe
in the future we put it somewhere
so you can have a look at it and of
course we're also thinking about cluster
brush 2.0 the next version of this
of this application
so in summary
as a data scientist you like to make
shiny applications but you have to be
aware that you're not a security
oriented programmer so make sure that
somebody else in our case the it
department is taking care of the
security and
that they provide a
safe environment in this case a docker
environment where you just put in your
application
so you have to really think about your
infrastructure and that means go talk to
these i.t people they
especially considering security at least
at our institute they know what they're
doing
and also ask yourself do you need all
the data if you create an application do
you need to connect that application to
all the corporate data you have or can
you just extract the and
only the data you need for this
for this application it means that in
case of a data breach not everything is
lost but just one piece of uh just a few
data points and the second thing is that
if you make a selection your application
will be here quite fast
also of course modules make you happy so
please do use
modules split your code
it's very important to know your user
you should talk to quite a lot about it
and
what i really like is that you have to
work as a team as you start with such an
application you put some people together
go sit with each other and just talk how
are we going to do this and how do we
like to work together and how do we
well
make this and make this work just a
little reflection on how you interact
with each other it can be very important
and it can be very fruitful to
to get the energy going in a team
and that's all for today
thank you so much yeah that's an amazing
presentation
it's awesome to see both both sides of
this too
and again we're all clapping although
you can't hear us if you can see in the
in the chat
there are a lot of great questions over
on slido
so i'll start asking a few of them
here from slido especially the anonymous
ones but we'd love to have people
jumping in and asking questions too so
feel free to raise your head your hand
on
zoom too
well one of the most upvoted anonymous
questions right now is as clusterbuster
began to be used by more people
did you face any performance issues
and how did you adjust your app to deal
with more concurrent users
really good question and something that
that we thought about when we first
started but the reality is that we we
create an application for professional
use so it's not the case that we have
hundreds or thousands of users at the
same time it's sometimes it's 10 users
at the same time for example so
um and this is not a problem for us
because our impact does not fully rely
on the amount of users that we have
some
sometimes it's it's it's um more
impactful to have one doctor look at it
than to have uh
10 other doctors look at it so for us
the numbers don't really say that much
but because this was a tool made for
professional use the users the number of
users was continuously low so we never
actually faced any problems in in
performance and also because we are
running this on openshift kubernetes
platform
um
well it will probably just scale up if
we run into any performance issues this
is a more relevant question for um for
following applications that we are
planning to to make public instead of
for public use instead of for
professional use
um i see another question that says
thanks for the great presentation how
did you gain the support of the i.t team
um because for some there may be a
little bit of hesitation regarding shiny
yeah
yeah well maybe
i didn't uh well i did notice some
pushback obviously someone even
literally said to me this is never going
to work
but as long as you just
stay positive and um
patient
at some points
i think it will all work out so
um
also what really helped was when we
showed the prototype or when we showed
the application itself this this really
helped so when we talked to people and i
showed the the application
they all of a sudden understood what we
were talking about
and
this this i believe was
a very helpful
yeah that's very important to have a
very open mic talk with this this it
people just
tell them that you want to put something
like the cluster bus so that you want to
put it on internet and just try to think
and work together how we can do this in
a secure way
and
at least rit departments
suddenly what you test is they
understand what you want and they are
thinking with you
[Music]
don't try to make them think against you
but try to find a common solution with
which actually works and
it's it's possible
also maybe the crisis help helped out a
little bit so in this case it was let's
get it done that was also the mindset so
at some points we had to just push
through
and say well we we need to do this
and i guess that's different in normal
situations but apart from that i think a
good honest talk as job said and showing
what your uh what your ideas are really
really helps
definitely thank you both
eve i see you asked a question um in
slido and i'd love to pull in some
people if you want to ask anything live
i
fix the ability to unmute yourself if
you want to jump in
and the question is can you say anything
about the
updating the frequency of the data the
update frequency of the data in sql
light in production
yeah
and chances they sent the data to us
once a day and
it's a usually
in the morning and now the data center
starts in the morning with all the
extraction and stuff like that and they
prepare the data sets that we use and
usually around noon
we run our scripts to create a database
so it's created on a daily basis so once
a day we create a new database with the
latest
numbers from actually then from
yesterday
so it's it's once a day but
if you want to do it more often it's
it's quite easy you can write it every
hour but the new date is only available
once a day so
great thank you
and i just put in the chat feel free to
raise your hand if you want to ask your
question live so you don't have to just
keep hearing me
reading them but the next one was which
model was used to define the clusters
right so from an epidemiological
standpoint i cannot really answer that
question but i can answer how the data
got constructed so um every time someone
got a positive test result he or she was
called by one of the employees at the
mhs's and was asked
with whom have you been in contact uh
where have you been where do you think
it's most likely that you've contracted
the the virus
and once three or more people were
saying that they most likely contracted
the virus at a specific place we would
call that a cluster
obviously if you scale up you would call
it an outbreak or a super outbreak
and the mhss would
write down these clusters would register
these classes and they would send that
to the rivm so that's the the starting
point for us to use for our
visualizations this was a separate
data file that they send us
thank you
thank you for an awesome presentation
can i ask you if you consider not using
a database
we we have considered this um
at first
different ways to go we were not really
sure what would be the best way to go so
we started off with uh with the database
and eventually stuck with it but
this is one of those things that that
from time to time you need to reevaluate
like is this the right way for for
clusterbuster 2.0 is this what you would
do i'm not totally convinced that we
would
um but
yeah there is something to say for
for using databases and something to to
save for using pins and just um
just our objects
um
you have something to add to that job
um
yeah well the the great thing is that of
course
in that database there are multiple
tables you you want to use
and it's very easy to make relations
between these tables
definitely you use a database
also if you put this information in our
object or in our environment
it's um
for me it's more difficult to work with
a database is such an easy
object and it's it's a single file and
you can work with it in iron but you can
also open it in a certain sqlite browser
just to inspect your data or
you can use it in uh
also you can use multiple applications
so it's much easier to have
multiple file connectors to the database
so
for me
i think uh i prefer a database over a
uh
some file based r object
so
one of them maybe
yeah
one of the ways you could look at this
is also from the performance perspective
so right now we are iterating over our
database to give back the data from a
specific region this is not a very fast
operation
so if you use um
i forgot the name of the package but we
do monitor the the performance of the of
the application and if we would notice
that it would take a lot of time to
produce
the visualizations
then i would definitely consider backing
off of a database so there are multitude
of considerations you need to make
so for now it's fine maybe because of
our small user group or the amount of
data that we have
but this is certainly a question that's
um that's on our mind
thank you
uh numish i see you have your hand
raised too
yeah hi uh i'm nimish chef
uh first of all thank you for a fabulous
presentation
um i'm
like a lot of people around the world
super interested in how
you know regardless of where on
in the world we are we're tracking covet
outbreaks and responding
um i'm originally from india and
i was super interested when india had a
big surge
um
april of last year
and i actually did some personal
uh
research into the data just to see if i
was in a position where i had to
intervene at what point do you do
something it's easy
when something happens and then you
react
to
but my question here is
i
understand that you had a separation of
data processing
so you had a team that took source data
and
did the transformations
that you then ingested
to work within your application
so the question is
what's the communication
because
the upfront data engineering is going to
do a certain amount of work
not
guaranteeing
a level of transformation that you want
in your application so is there a
two-step process or are you giving them
requirements
i guess it's a little bit of both so i
am part of the team that does the etl
using r actually so i was um uh
pretty up to date with what they were
doing but eventually we noticed that
there was some distance between team
cluster buster and the team that's doing
the the etl
so this is where fleur comes in she's
the latest uh
member of our team and she works for the
team that does the data preparation but
she's also part of team cluster buster
so we noticed that there was some
risk of mis miscommunication and that's
where we decided to to narrow the the
bonds
so this is a very very very good and
important point you uh you make and uh
something that i was
uh very aware of and finally we had to
take steps in order to prevent some
miscommunication from happening yeah
yeah this is where vertical integration
is is such an important part so
as long as it's possible to vertically
integrate these different skills into
your team it prevents miscommunication
so this is one of the aspects where it
was very hard to do so but we eventually
managed to to form some some link to
prevent miscommunication
thank you
great thank you
thank
you i know booty i i see you also asked
a question i'll read it but jump in if
you have any other context to add
but it was this is a rapidly evolving
disease how often do you collect
feedback from users and update your app
right so i had the meetings with the
advisory board on a weekly
base basis
so we spoke to them
very often
and i work at the at the rfm i'm
literally surrounded by doctors and
epidemiologists when i'm i'm there so
i'm i'm um
always up to date on the on the latest
of the latest so
um
how often do you change that is a good
question because you do not want to
become neurotic in what you develop so
this is where your focus on value is so
important
but we did have to change a couple of
times and i i had this idea that we
should
sort of move along with the the epidemic
so at a certain point vaccination was
more important so we started focusing on
that
right now we're at the omicron phase
this brings in new challenges so we have
to stay flexible but not neurotic i
think that's that's the most important
part
i like that
um i see there's a
bunch of other anonymous questions too
and one was
was your data loaded into docker in a
form of some aggregates how did you
create them
this one's for you
what we did is that we
of course when we had these already
prepared
data sets and we made our own selections
out of these data sets and then put it
into the sqlite database it's not
aggregated data it's it contains
individual data points
the actual personal information is is
removed but still it's individual
medical data so it's still
have to comply with all these privacy
regulations
and then we have this database which is
a single file
and
at our container solution which is uh
red hat's openshift it's connected to
kubernetes we can add a persistent
storage to a
container and what we do is that we copy
this this database to that persistent
storage of that container and when the
container starts it's actually mounting
this persistent storage
[Music]
file directory and then it can access
the database so this is a bit how it
works
and the next question was
which is the main advantage of keeping
it all in r with shiny instead of using
streamlet power bi or tableau for
example
did you feel you were at any point
sacrificing on simplicity
well no no i understand where this
question is coming from like maybe it's
easier to build a dashboard using uh
power bi
this could be the case but however we
had the
the skills to to build on our shiny
application and
this is the interesting part i started
working with our shiny with two new
members of the team that does the data
preparation these were people that are
skilled in r but not so much in our
shiny
and we managed to to build a new
application from scratch
within uh
let's say two months so with no
experience
we got to to create an application in
our shiny within two months and this was
part time this was a couple of hours a
week that we were working on this so it
is not as hard as you might think the
the advantages of having the same
language through the entire analytics
pipeline uh fastly outweigh the the
complexity of creating our shiny
application
it does take some
some getting used to the idea of
modularization
uh and obviously there are are a couple
of questions that you really need to
wrap your mind around but once you get
there it's it's it's very doable
especially if you have our skills and
you work in tidy first then um
yeah
as i said it's uh the the advantages
falsely outweigh the the disadvantages
here
thank you and
left left tourist i see you asked a
question on slido 2 um so if you want to
jump in
please feel free to do so
but the question was did you use any
specific method to increase the
performance of your application
and did you scope your data or load it
all in the global file
yeah considering the the performance
of course we use
we profiled the application uh while it
was running
with profits and just see what are the
uh
the things would just take
most of the time and uh it usually means
the first step where you have to load
the data from the database into memory
so the user can work
with it
[Music]
by using a database it also means that
you can have most of the data just on
file and you just use a a query using a
dbplier and only collect the data you
want to use and that's actually the
somebody logs in it only gets the data
from a specific region and that's
actually the data frame you're working
with
most of the time in the
in the database
and so
in short the
we have quite a large database and now
we have about
10 thousands of infections each each day
so it's getting actually bigger and
bigger and bigger so you also see the
applications get a little bit slower but
as soon as the data is loaded
then the application is as fast as as
always
so that's the uh
so what we do is that we select the data
from the database only the selected data
is
put in some i i'm not even sure it's
it's in in a global uh i think that we
use a global data frame for certain uh
certain
visualizations
some are selected at
the level of a module it depends
when we
um started off i thought like five
seconds uh loading time is too much it
needs to be
instant i think we we passed five
seconds now for some visualizations and
and we probably could do better with uh
with um
react log and profits
but in all honesty it's like sometimes
that the metaphor is like when are you
gonna change the wheels on the bus when
you're going over the highway at 130
miles an hour so it's quite difficult to
to optimize at this moment but um in all
honesty i think this this does deserve a
little bit more attention from uh from
us
a question that i wanted to ask earlier
too was um
around the prototype that you built and
the process that you went through
because i feel like that was so
important for getting everybody on board
was that
that was sure to shiny up say oh or
what was the process from doing that
well i created it just in our studio uh
in the month of december i did some work
on our shiny before i started working at
the rivm so i had a lot of code
already sitting there
ready to be used so that was very
helpful
so i think i created this in uh
i don't know maybe a week or so and then
we put it on shiny apps that i o
just for some uh no i didn't even put it
on shiny episode i just ran it locally
and showed it to people i was just
sitting in my office waving at people
wanting to uh telling them to come in
and take a look at the application and
afterwards we put it on shiny
shinyapps.i o and we could show it to
two more people
but uh yeah
a bit of improvisation there
cool
this application this was a dui
application containing fake data of
course obviously yeah
but i see dan also asked a question
through slido that was
how did you make sure regions and news
users felt comfortable using your app
so you're not just fielding questions
that are answered within the app
yeah that's that's a really good
question i think
it helps that we are from the national
institute i think that really helps
because we are a trusted institute and
the
municipal health services i think have a
good relationship with our organization
so
that's that's
um
that helped
and also giving the presentations just
showing the people that um
that we were working very very hard in
order to to create valuable insights for
them
and not just assume that they will find
the
the application go to them put in effort
and earn the trust i think that was that
was also really important
yeah but it wasn't uh it was not
necessarily a given that they trusted
our application
at all times
yeah
thank you and
a few of the other questions just going
through one um
a few more technical ones about docker
let's see one on one
what types of businesses are hotbeds for
covid clusters has this information
informed policy changes
by people have used it
that's a good question so there's a
lot of data being collected
on
clusters and
some of this is presented in the cluster
buster not all of it but all of it is
used
in our
how do you say this national council
national advisory board on uncovered
and they definitely use this data to um
in our models they use this data to to
form um
policies surrounding the battling covet
of 19.
but this was not so so public policy
making on a national level was not
influenced by the cluster buster but on
a local level it was in a way influenced
think for example of the allocation of
these mobile vaccination units i think i
think that's a good example so that
that's one very practical thing that
they use the cluster buster for
to to optimize but
they were not opening schools because
the cluster buster said it was safe to
do so it it didn't go like that
tom fowler i see you just put a a
question to the chat if you'd like to
jump in
yeah thanks um yes i got someone
yeah great presentation guys thank you
that was um really interesting
um you mentioned towards the start that
some of the data quality issues improved
over the course of the rollout
engagement with your users
great to know a little bit more about
that
obviously good data in helps create good
output and
bad data
isn't great
no exactly so this was as i said like a
side effect but a very important one for
us so one of the examples is that
when they were uh writing down the
clusters they sometimes forgot the to
add the postal code which was something
that we used to give a cluster location
on a map
so at one point one of the mhs has
contacted me and said well we don't see
any visualizations of our clusters but
they were not giving us the information
to do so so that we had a conversation
about what we were missing and then they
started filling out the postal codes so
they were improving their data quality
and that helped us to give them back the
the insights
another example is that they were using
a software program to do all their
registrations but at some point they
have to
click an option that says send this to
the rivm and they were not always doing
that so we actually put up a notice on
the dashboard saying if you want
to have these insights make sure that
you
actually activate that button and a lot
of them actually
start doing better in that regard
yeah great it's that feedback loop that
i think is really important that you
know always always needs to be called
out great thanks thank you
definitely yeah definitely so
uh obviously one of the questions that
they ask is why do we need to to
register this this is we are already
very very busy what's the use of us
putting this
specific detail down and
by providing insights they got a part of
the answer on that question like this is
why you do it and
oftentimes that would help them in their
motivation obviously
uh yeah but i think this is a question
for you um they said maybe i missed it
but did you use a ci cd for the shiny
docker kubernetes workflow
yeah so that's what we did uh i think i
forgot to mention it but
as soon as we update one of the testing
accept or
production versions in our
git environment
that immediately kicks off a new rebuild
of the of the container
and so this is what i call continuous
deployments the the
continuous integration now for some with
integration tests
i love to do that but
we haven't done it yet
thank you
um two
other questions that were there on slido
and again if there was a burning
question that i missed from the chat
window and zoom to
jump in
but it is did you have any functionality
within your apps to send individual
level data to
municipalities
no
no we didn't so um
we added a download button at some
at a specific point in our dashboard but
uh we were very wary of
providing options to download the the
data for obvious reasons you don't want
this data to just float around
so we limited we limited the sharing of
personal data there are other options in
which the mhss can get personal
get more detailed information from the
rfvm but most of them already have it so
no through the cluster buster we were
not really providing
any personal details
this was also not the point of the
cluster buster so um the point of the
cluster buster was to um
to help doctors and epidemiologists gain
an understanding of the covered 90's
situation and this is
the numbers were so great the the
individual level was not important
i see fernando just asked in the chat if
you have some resources on using modules
and shiny and that can be a question for
anyone on the call if you have any
resources you want to share in the chat
yeah i think there are on the uh the uh
what's it the only our studio websites
unlock articles there are very good
reasons
that's how i started also
on youtube you'll find some
our user conference of our studio
conference
presentations about
shiny modules
so there's just plenty of information
about it
and the most important thing is just
just try it's um
shiny models when you start it's a bit
difficult to wrap your head around but
as soon as you get it's done it's it's
getting easier and easier but
just try and ask around of course if you
don't
know what to do
definitely
one of the
last questions i saw on slido was for
huge amounts of data have you tested out
file types like rda or parquet to store
your data set within your containers
that's it's not for cluster bus so we
have other applications with used files
with with many data where it's a concern
but we started with clusterbuster the
the the current way of using escolite
was fast enough now we are
running into situations that we think
will might be faster today or
getting it faster would be nice
but for other applications we
know we want to look into it
um but it's very depending on the type
of data and how you use it in your
application so
actually when you're
starting off it's it's
it's always good to think about it and
do some tests
it really depends on what you want to do
it with your data
thank you thank you for answering all
these questions too i know i'm throwing
a lot of questions at you and we're
getting right until the end of time here
so i'd love to just
ask one more question
for people who are on the call who are
maybe in this position of
just starting to
use shiny or they have this idea of
something that could help the business
or organization
what is one piece of feedback you would
give them for
just getting started with that first
project
start small just
take something relatively simple
um
make it
uh look good
once again i'm sorry to emphasize this
but it is important if you want to
convince decision makers
then definitely do so but start start
out with something small and this is one
of the reasons why um we are working
towards making something open source
because i think we can help you guys um
get a head start with this i really hope
uh we can we can help you guys
so more data-driven uh
healthcare is always good
but um yeah just
start with something small make sure it
looks good it works good and i use that
to convince your your uh decision makers
awesome thank you
yeah do you have anything else sad or a
tip you would give people
um
now i think if it at least if you work
at
a big corporate or or an issue like us
go talk with your i.t department uh just
discuss things uh
what you want and and try to find
solutions but
keep an open mind and keep an open talk
with these guys
and and finally you will find something
which works for everybody so
maybe one last thing to add and there is
a a great blog on this on the website of
our studio i believe it was on
why a code first approach is is a good
thing to do
and i think it's really
wise to read through this and understand
the reasoning behind this because a code
first approach
really does help
for example if you want to open source
the way you work well you need you need
code code is reproducible
for quality assurance and quality
control code is a code is a good thing
to have so there are
um a couple of
very convincing reasons to work with uh
with the code first approach but go read
the blog
and i think that will give you some
background into our arguments for for
this as well
thank you i think i put the right one
there
um i know there's a few different ones
on code first but i'll try and gather
all the resources that were shared in
the chat too when i share the recording
and we'll share the slides there too
i just want to say thank you so much to
both of you for the awesome
presentations and just being so open
with us and sharing all that you learned
i really appreciate it
and thank you all for joining too it's
great to see all the
amazing questions
well thanks for the opportunity it was
it was a thank you very much
yeah
indeed my pleasure
[Music]
you